Andy Rubin head of Google's Android team
until 2013 famously defined androids
openness with this tweet offering the
instructions for downloading and
building the Android source code as app
developers it's handy to be able to peek
behind the curtains and see how the
framework actually works and it's an
excellent way to find answers to tricky
Stack Overflow questions but the Android
Open Source project or AOSP as it's
commonly known is much more than that
the source code is available under the
Apache 2 license so anyone can take it
and do anything they want with it
including modifying it and
redistributing it and they have Android
has always had a passionate community of
models from Steve Kondik in the cyanogen
community to XDA and many others who
have been distributing modified images
of android for phone owners brave enough
to try them even big companies like
Amazon have taken the Android source
code and modified it for use in their
own line of products that openness
extends to the apps themselves the AOSP
includes key mobile apps like the dialer
app launched a calendar and email and
Google Offers its own versions of each
as well in the early days those native
apps were tightly bound to the framework
and could only get updated along with
the platform which admittedly in the
early days seemed like every few weeks
but as the time between platform
releases grew so did the efforts to
unbundle those apps allowing them to be
updated through Google Play that was
great news for users but it had an even
better side effect for us developers
because apps like Gmail and that's
depend on a number of proprietary google
api is Google released Google Play
services also codenamed after food to
support the Google apps while also
giving us developers Google's specific
API is like Maps wallet Drive in YouTube
so now we get the latest and greatest
Google specific API is every six weeks
or so and rather than being tied to a
specific platform they're available on
every device back to Gingerbread oh and
of course every native app is also
entirely replaceable so you can publish
apps to replace any of the apps shipped
with the device and we can build our own
SMS apps home screens or Maps apps
publish it on Play and give users the
choice to make a ded fault when Android
was first announced Andy Rubin described
the AOSP as live the software to run a
mobile phone but without the proprietary
obstacles that it
mobile innovation today Android runs on
more than just Mobile's but the core of
its purpose remains the same a platform
an ecosystem that allows modders
carriers OMS and app developers to
innovate and compete so armed with an
open evolving platform enriched by a
growing set of Google API s and the
ability to create great apps that let
users customize every aspect of their
user experience you can use other
people's work to help define the
computing platform of the future and
that's my definition of open